Speaker 1: One of the things we've learned
to pay special attention to over the last few
years is when the American Republican Party
says this is what the left is going to do.
We should look really carefully at whether
what they mean is we're actually already
doing this. And when it comes to voter fraud,
we've increasingly learned that all of the fear
mongering and all of the allegations about
what Democrats and the Left are going to
do was actually stuff that almost exclusively
it was Republicans doing people voting twice,
people voting in the names of dead people. All of
these different things. We see endless instances
on the right. And Donald Trump's former chief
of staff, Mark Meadows, is now really caught in
the crosshairs. I recently told you guys
that Meadows is under investigation for
was he registered to vote where he actually
lived? There's some really fishy stuff going on,
and the latest news is that Mark Meadows
has indeed now been removed from the North
Carolina voter rolls in the middle of
this investigation. Axios reporting
former White House Chief of Staff Mark Meadows was
removed from North Carolina's voter role Monday.
Why it matters The move comes amid an
investigation into Meadows for alleged voter fraud
related to his voter registration. The probe
followed reports which revealed that Meadows
registered to vote in North Carolina in September
2020, using an address he allegedly never visited.
State of play Meadows was removed from the
North Carolina voter role after documentation
indicated Oh, he lived in Virginia and
last voted in the 2021 election there.
No formal challenge has been received by the Macon
County Board of Elections. The last election he
voted in Macon County was 2020 under state law.
If a North Carolina voter exercises the right of
a citizen by voting in an election in another
state. The person is considered to have lost
their North Carolina residents. Now there's two
issues here. Remember, Republicans kept talking
about people registered to vote in two places.
That's not against the law. As long as you don't
vote in two places, it's very common that somebody
lives in one place and you register and then you
move somewhere else and you register there. You're
not automatically removed from the registration at
the old place. You're registered in two places. I
believe Tiffany Trump, Trump's daughter, had this
going on. As long as you don't vote twice, it's
OK. You haven't actually done anything wrong.
The next part with the Mark Meadows investigation
is the register, the address where he was
supposedly registered to vote or where he was
registered to vote, where he supposedly lived
was not a place he had allegedly even been to. If
I recall correctly, it was a trailer of some kind,
and the circumstances are all extraordinarily
bizarre. Now it shouldn't come as a complete
and total shock to us that this is really common.
But also remember that Donald Trump multiple times
talked about You should try voting twice this all
of this vote by mail thing. It's so complicated
that maybe you should try voting twice. Here's
just one time that Donald Trump said this Mark
Meadows was Trump's chief of staff at this time.
Speaker 3: Sign your mail in ballot, OK, you sign
it right and send it in, and then you have to
follow it. And if on Election Day or early voting
that is not tabulated and counted, you go
vote. And then if for some reason after that,
it shouldn't take that long. It comes in.
They're not going to be able to tabulate
it because you will have voted. But you have
to make sure your vote counts because the only
way they're going to beat us is by doing that
Speaker 1: kind of stuff. So Trump said even
if you submit a Mail-In vote, you should still
go and try to vote again because if they don't
receive anyway. But what he's saying is try to
vote twice, try to vote twice. And of course,
it all is predicated on the idea that the mail in
votes are going to just end up some some kind of
netherworld, some kind of election purgatory of
sorts. But remember, they never actually cared
about voter fraud. They never really cared about
it. They care about what are the ways in which
they can weaponize confusion and misinformation
to help themselves when they want to use v